one only fifty seven square mails from
transit of the canal 6 heaps of name
emissions per capita of Peru is
national vers
louis at police operations of tiger's
the leaders of many of the gang's
involved in these 93
wang gang and sarita colony
jered bites field leader not a co
in case of such paco you have
information was the intelligence group
from the silent region of that previously
they did a job of
of research work
intelligence verified in this that such
payment in companion 300 were to the frontis
of a
of a property in the jurisdiction of
exit colony and in those circumstances
was where the intervention in
his neighbours baco westfield unexpected
builders an idea the yang steppe
bakos ever presents carlos the hitman
diego with my bike and tania so much command in
the corner like your
catch more rain work on rowing came
I had to make a little note early
one round and discarded me at four o'clock
the morning what for consolation gates
direct western one of the west wing
king with them then axel the under cover
police station
when the time in west right in life and
gay designated by the police and his rage
action task force interview
in the morning he calls me I come with my motorcycle
and I saw all the tubes all fixed
in arms applying a head to him to lower
the two advertising carts the
whites all this in civil
unfortunately he was killed in the case of
the shooting was like that as 60 lead judges
no but today 4 in the morning I left because
If not now I was dead tell
saved my brother's life was
prisoner and this to me did not have many many
dead over nor water the finados
wronged one day we are at a party
through our neighborhood a site takes out the
my friend's friend dance
confidence in myself is to respect them to
see things come on here started listening to
the ten minutes only 15 lead well the
body room came out smoke
back on live and the gang of that web of
blessed friends mtv games for work
[Music]
in the callao criminal sustenance and comment
grade levels of aspect navigation under
live be celebrated and 2010
[Music]
Miguel Soft did you do 'gang bang' version
bandits when considering so much football not
some memory peter's tumbstone
falling criminals offensive turns
wifinger communities
virgil it's not only for the devil's
third round criminal it is the fashion
the monumental volunteer art gallery
it's holden and exhibition from pixel
quiet underworld realism
the works everett is burning down local
artist Aaron Lopez try things but
Peruvian dog
and so the eggs
[Music]
what I portrayed is the reality
basically they are portraits of people who
is in many cases outside the law
and what I do is it's a
a kind of tribute to the circumstance
of their life
in these four characters are bandits
basically these people are hidden and
away from the law
Here I tell you about leger and co
yoriko is an apprentice malandro who
shape the head as the routes
wrong and stuck a lot to the drug and
I divert all his whole criminal career
that I had started to build me
you understand right now he's imprisoned in sarita
then you me
more or less
This is the left-handed, I have a lot of appreciation
of surfing actually
did a good pass always gave or have
given enough to the neighborhood
well of fondeport trades arons exhibition
the pits symbol software show of
linguist and it's spicy and familiar so
what residents
here I have a typical bodegón of 2016
it became very fashionable to extort
they left it at the door of your house
with a little note tomorrow
the typical floral arrangements of
from deceased to tomorrow one of my cousins
fell they dropped six pens or because they
got with the woman who should not
now his brother is in prison
I was lucky that my parents
they educated why that is the debt that I
I have to portray people who from
some way it's not because they have
wanted to leave in that direction
you understand and it has not been the
circumstances
back in sarita colonia at the level of
chinchón shows my friend the prosecutor is the
manchego player
he had his vices and as anyone has
had neither for the palomeada nor for the
police or for nobody took to
find out why he was killed
we get to tiwinza depure section o
sarita colonia and women and drogar its
live
if you live and rock the
he is a boy that I know very small
the modeling of permission to live from here
you're just the generation outside the
people
jona
then
if you do not pay
by appointment
I wish human condition in which the small
and his put them as a result of the
decision you live and the basic page is
ok hand
the human being has been one day I was raining
me in b whose my lungs
covered with a cigar so that help
that there is to my lung the price of
cigar lungs 16 and quest stadium ni
fast
of species lost from such factors
fast sets the new living and billy
[Music]
in these evils of rifai
leave the toxic and vice I was your
transactions addicted formulas of slams
official in the import-export be but
webber and verín cuisine availability o
chip kokein from late now we camp david
popular slam waller software silent
I have three that I have had
[Music]
22 hours from 22 and 3 and how much and how much
each one costs
each shampoo 5
I started to value at the age of
in the two years that is called pasta
local marijuana and now
I am 50 years old
And I'm feeling good
if he stopped using this
if all the diseases come to me
I will reach the ground download the
containers
that I've lost family like that but my
family by
but good jobs
and now that
of copsa of the local police station and
they anticipate touching the routine operation
gamer adapt getting red bulls for
defend ourselves we need the support and
participation of each and every one of
your
staff as rows
but
[Music]
ah
they are given turned into the operation and
emergency colque minister of police
annual trade until now
Rest
it's a voice that comes
rest
s
is very pretty
m
but seeing the presence of leaks
out of this kind of ajuterique habitat by
local drug next to be here you leslie
you tube defect of substances
jasmine
[Music]
now
Y
[Applause]
i
we went out we went out
the family of the children
in a criminal hunter gardener stetzer
beltrones biffle on occasion i was found
distributing rocks
satherley that good road of al
descobert ernest some trace straight
to window
but to the two steps the step
true
front left
[Music]
when they saw against them
up to the public that I found
women are not dedicated to the micro are
Many
wrap soft and visible at your choice max
payne
credit cards under different everything ready
they read
basic paste or because it's just read
where any manufacturing process
toxic Israeli way very addictive and I have
what to drink and chip
295 people
because the thought responds to
collaborate now
one
facebook has a wide viewer of his
writing of the ways that while
visual division 28 that the rest of
civilians weeks floor life and death '
improvised by lnd city